Hi.
Thank you.
Welcome.
My name is Magali [inaudible] Martinez and my co Creator in all things.
Genesis Watson.
Hartsough.
Um,
so a little bit,
we'll talk a about,
uh,
genesis.
What is,
what is genesis,
what we aim to do?
Um,
so genesis is a nonprofit here in Los Angeles that aims to foster and strengthen
and expand access to dynamic and interactive and comprehensive,
um,
stem experiences primarily in underserved communities throughout Los Angeles.
Um,
so we do this by dropping a mobile stem lab,
state of the art mobile stem lab.
It's about like 36 feet.
And we interchange it with anything from computers and laptops to three d
printers to laser cutters.
We can,
for whatever stem experience we want to create,
we,
we re we shifted around so that it fits the theme and the experiences that we
want the young people to,
to have.
Um,
again,
we're primarily dropping this genesis mobile innovation lab in underserved
communities,
high poverty areas with underperforming schools.
Um,
we are popup experiences have included robotics and assisted devices or our
young people have actually built,
um,
and three d printed hands for about accounts that they sent to children in third
world countries that had lost their lens.
Um,
we also have a game design lab,
so we will shift our pod,
that's what we call our mobile innovation lab.
Our pod,
we shifted and turn it into a k a game studio.
Um,
this summer we introduced smart machines and smart cities are two latest stem
popup experiences.
And you'll see here where we're actually going to demo our smart machines,
which was designed and built and iterated over three popups with about 60 group,
60 young people from harbor city to southeast Los Angeles to South La.
Um,
okay.
And so,
uh,
at the center or we sent her all of our experiences in design principles that
meant most of the design principles come out of the MIT media lab.
I'm Mitchell Resnick's work,
which was inspired by pairs work,
which is centered on constructivism and hands on learning.
So are our design principles augment a child's experience with stem learning no
matter what their interest level.
So there's many paths,
many styles.
It's hands on,
self directed,
a constructivist transparent.
What we mean by transparent is we bring the,
the inside of the machine outside,
we want the kids to be able to see what,
um,
what creates,
what's the inside pieces that make these machines and tech go.
Um,
we emphasize process over product and of course we're experimenting,
exploring.
And as a result,
the young people are constantly discovering.
Our goal is 100% engagement.
Every single time we pop up.
Um,
the goal is 100%.
And so far so good.
So far,
so good.
If you,
if you come to our popups,
uh,
you'll see a 100% engagement and,
and
100%.
So all the students that come in,
let's say we have 40 students,
it usually we have about 2018 to 20 students.
All 20 students are engaged in some aspect or some element of the experience.
So it's designed with multiple points of entry.
We'll have arts and crafts at one table.
We call it our operating system.
So it's like this little hub where there's tinkering,
there's designing,
there's arts and crafts,
there's world building,
their storytelling,
computer programming.
Everyone has an opportunity to touch every aspect of the hub,
but then they also choose where they're going to spend the rest of their time.
Um,
so that's what I mean.
Does that answer the question?
Sweet.
Um,
um,
we're going to actually play a video while I share the story of,
of young hot when I'm so hot.
When,
uh,
we met at a 49th street elementary school in southeast Los Angeles.
And just to paint a little picture,
southeast La,
um,
is a neighborhood with high levels of poverty underperforming schools.
Um,
uh,
one of the days that we were there,
we,
we had to lock down the campus because the helicopters,
you know,
we're hovering really low.
And the kid said,
okay,
we have to go.
We have to go on lockdown.
Um,
so just to give you a sense of the communities that we're dropping into,
this is a unique opportunity for,
for the young folks.
Um,
it's Kinda like the carnival is coming into town,
the circus is coming into town.
Um,
but it's a stem circus.
So when this young child,
the staff,
um,
afterwards when I went to meet with the staff,
they said to me,
um,
we weren't sure if hot when,
if we were going to let him participate because he has a severe learning
disability and um,
they let him come to our,
our,
our pop up.
I'm glad they did.
As soon as I noticed how it,
when I noticed he was fidgeting,
he was trying to stay in place,
but he was moving around,
moving around.
So I walked over to him and I shared,
I gave him some pipe cleaners and a job.
I said,
hey,
can you help me create,
um,
some,
I can't remember what it was,
some element of our smart machine.
At first he looked at me,
you know,
before I add,
before I gave him the job,
like he was nervous,
like he was going to get kicked out.
And when I gave him the job,
he just smiled beaming wide.
Together,
we're working on the pipe cleaners.
And it wasn't until later that I realized that he had a severe learning
disorder,
learning disability.
We worked with him.
Uh,
he worked with all of us.
That was,
this is the day that our Googlers,
um,
came to join us and he actually built some of the most intricate,
most detailed,
um,
what were those bumpers?
Those are bumpers,
right?
Yeah.
He,
he built some of the most intricate,
most detailed bumpers that we had seen in the entire trajectory.
All three popups.
His bumpers were the most detailed and creative.
Um,
when I went back to talk to,
to the,
to his,
to the staff at les best,
they said that his parents thank them for allowing him to be a part of the
genesis popup.
Um,
because prior to that,
the only subjects he talked about are the only topics he talked about.
Um,
where Jim in lunch,
and this was the first time that he talked about computers.
So the parents are very,
um,
they wanted to know more,
how can we get our kid involved in more,
um,
computer classes.
Now I have to tell you about my little friend Andre.
He was over at challengers,
um,
boys and girls club.
And the reason I share these stories,
these inspired beginning stories is just to give you a face.
Um,
and,
and you know,
real young people that are experiencing these popups.
We save these numbers.
We've reached over 150 to 200 kids this summer.
Um,
but just to give you a sense of that,
the young people that we are touching and reaching and connecting with Andre,
he's about six years old.
Um,
he was considered one of the most challenged members at the club.
I didn't know that.
We invite everyone multiple paths of entry.
As long as he was interested.
He kept wandering over to our pod.
I'm wandering over to our tents and didn't want to join his group,
his age group.
And we said,
that's okay.
He can stay.
And so staff members kept coming up to me,
is it okay if he stays?
I said,
yeah,
he could stay.
So he was there every single day and other younger kids started to join the pop
up.
So we ended up,
we had originally had 30 scheduled and we ended up with about 60 in that one.
Uh,
challengers.
And so Andre was the cutest.
Uh,
he,
he was always getting in trouble at the club,
but they knew that if he was over at the pop up at Genesis,
he was fine.
He was not going to be,
he was not going to get in trouble.
Um,
they would ask him,
the staff members would ask him,
Hey,
what are you doing over there?
It's like,
oh,
I'm being creative.
And so when,
when he'd asked staff members,
could he leave to go to genesis?
They said,
well,
what,
where do you,
what are you going to go do?
He says,
well,
I'm going to go do science.
So for us,
it was this beautiful moment of him realizing that science and creativity,
um,
they work together,
they can be fun.
Um,
so I met his foster mom afterwards and she said,
oh,
my son keeps coming home talking about computers and creativity and science.
Um,
is this,
you know,
what's genesis?
And so I introduced them to some more steam programs in the community.
Um,
but she said we've been trying to figure out a way to get him engaged in stem.
Uh,
but he never showed any interest.
So that's,
that's Andre and then,
uh,
yeah.
All right.
So where we met Andre and hot when we met them at our genesis stems summer pop
up,
uh,
you see here next to me,
smart pinball machine made 100%,
well not 100% cause we got some tech,
but it's made from sustainable from recycled materials.
We go to a place called trash for teaching and Gardena and pick up,
well was it a hundred pounds of stuff?
Yeah,
like a hundred plus pounds of recycled trash materials.
And we dropped them off with all these kids.
And we have a few,
you know,
we have some guidelines and some structures in place,
but we're basically saying to them,
hey,
your design challenge is to create a smart pinball machine that not only you
want to play,
but also that other young people throughout Los Angeles will want to play.
And so this is our smart machine powered by the imagination of young people.
Um,
I am going to hand off to my Buddy Watson,
uh,
he's going to talk a bit about how the machine was transformed in ways that we
could not have imagined.
He'll just take us through the trajectory of the smart machine and because
there's so few of us here,
is it okay if people kind of come up for this part of the talk?
Is that okay?
Come on up.
If you want to stay seated.
That's,
that's cool too.
But come take a look at the machine that was and
built and created by,
I dunno,
60 plus kids
and Watson.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
um,
luckily for us,
most kids don't know what pinball machines are anymore.
So,
um,
our,
our job of reimagining the pinball machine was made much easier because we
didn't have them saying,
well,
this doesn't look like a pinball machine.
Um,
and really we sort of like boiled it down to a few different skills that we
wanted to scaffold on top of this.
Um,
and they were all around rapid prototyping,
experimentation,
testing and tinkering because we're asking them to build something that nobody
really knew how to build.
We had no idea what this was going to look at.
It was completely a codesign process with them.
Um,
clearly whenever they're using,
um,
like there'd be like,
oh,
I want to cut a whole year so we're not going to just hand out exacto knives.
Um,
one of us will help them make their designs into reality.
but as we were moving through this design process,
um,
what we ended up seeing was that the more open space we gave for them,
the more we were impressed with what they came up with.
That was beyond what we could imagine.
Um,
so for those of you who are classic pin ballers,
um,
you should know there are elements that are incorporated into this that do
resemble and original pinball machine.
So,
um,
we sort of broke it down into three simple game mechanics to explain to them.
Um,
you have targets which are buttons that you hit that give you points.
This is connected using a Makey Makey to uh,
a simple graphic programming language called scratch,
which is out at Mit.
I'm an obstacle is anything that gets in the way of you hitting a target and
getting points.
And then a bumper is something that's really not maliciously trying to stop you
from getting points,
but you can bump into it and it'll spin or light up or something like this.
Something kind of like what hot created.
Um,
sorta just adding,
adding to the experience of the machine tells me how to slope.
Um,
yeah,
so,
so the,
the other important piece of,
of the game,
um,
is,
is are these robotic balls,
um,
for the name of Sphero.
Um,
so the kids,
you can learn basic programming with these,
but it's a lot more fun to just drive them and control them.
Um,
at the center of the design challenge for making the game as smug Elise was
saying is it has to be fun.
It can't be,
um,
something that just sits here and looks like a pile of trash.
This is like carefully engineered fun.
This was like everything here is here with a purpose.
Um,
and the fun that we had was structured on this idea that in pinball it needs to
be a game of skill.
So not anybody can just walk up to it and come and beat the game.
You have to really,
um,
have practiced and you have to know how to control this fall.
So out of that,
um,
immediately whenever you have a hoard of kids around when these machines,
it became apparent that we needed a way to say your turn is over.
And,
um,
the kids came up with that in an elegant way.
Um,
let's see,
like giving me the controller.
So thus was born the idea of the trap.
And as you can see it there,
there's a trap over here.
There's a trap.
Um,
this is sort of like the pit of despair.
Once you go inside this box,
it's very hard to get out.
Um,
but all of these were sort of mechanisms that the kids came up with to make it
to the game,
kept moving and it had a,
had a rhythm and allowed everybody to play it.
Um,
one of the most beautiful parts of this,
the testing of this machine is that we do try to get in,
um,
expand access to the machine and the test,
the play testing period.
So,
um,
our young designers who'd been working throughout the week on this at the end of
the week,
um,
get to present it to the rest of the boys and girls club and have younger kids
come and play and get their feedback.
What's fun,
what wasn't fun,
what would be cool?
This would be neat if I had plexi glass this,
it'd be cool if it blew up right here.
Like this would be cool if it made a cat noise.
Um,
but it,
it was just another way to get the input of,
of this other generation of kids,
multiple things going on.
Yeah.
So we actually,
we are,
this is a,
I guess the fourth iteration.
Yeah,
there were many iterations within,
in between them.
But for the example,
this trap was created by the first group of kids in South Bay and then I believe
these were created and with those charges,
yeah.
Can,
we had a total of three popups.
Um,
yeah.
And then this was challengers as well.
It was actually really interesting to see how they were building on top of each
other's ideas.
And then how our final papa you can talk a little bit more about challenges and
how they activated the,
they really opened up the imagination for more arts and story and world building
at challengers.
Yeah.
So this thing has been through a lot.
It has a,
it has more tape than anything else at this point it seems like and that is
because this thing has been played.
Um,
ms thing has been used by kids and it was in a really,
really sorry state at our last pop up.
Um,
and we gave these to sort of more experienced designers where we said,
all right your guys job and make this just as sturdy as possible.
And there are all these like inbuilt little obstacles that we had made where
they're like,
oh,
this'll be great for them to put electronics on and stuff.
And these kids in this redesign,
they just got rid of everything I just said.
It's a box now,
but it's a strong box
in what the,
what this did though is it opened up the game board completely and now there was
no real constraint.
There weren't walls anymore.
There were just these boxes that can be taken on and off.
And when that happened,
each of these boxes became a different world.
The kids were able to start designing them.
So there was some star wars kids that were like,
this is the dark side because it's really,
really challenging and like nobody wants to go up this,
um,
this was considered to be like this like Celestial Palace,
up here where that's like worth the most points,
but it's also very challenging to get to the pit of despair clearly is some
place you want to avoid.
Um,
but as this was happening,
um,
it opened up this whole other world of,
of kids being able to come and start getting engaged with it.
If you see that little character right there,
um,
these started getting reproduced at a amazing rate.
One Kidney,
I had to do it.
And he taught all the other kids and quickly,
all the levels got filled up with these characters.
Um,
and they're,
they're so cute.
They all got taken afterwards because the kids love them.
But we're able to save one.
Um,
but,
but it was sort of this realization at the end of the day as I just sat staring
at this,
um,
sort of like open box was that in a way,
what this is,
is a,
a new sandbox,
right?
Um,
and what it's doing is mixing digital and physical computing in a single space.
So you're able to,
to use trash,
you're able to use tape,
you're able to use things that are engaging for somebody who likes to use their
hands,
but you're also learning the basics of computational thinking,
um,
in a way that you really sort of like,
it's like you get tricked into taking your medicine,
right?
Uh,
and then with,
you know,
the Sphero and we also activated ozobots.
You can program them so you can teach young people and in very incremental
steps,
programming and computer programming.
And by them being able to place it inside of the game right away,
they have that instant gratification that they can see,
feel and touch and also challenged their friends.
Hey,
I programmed it to do this and I did that better than you.
Or maybe we can work together to challenge the next group of kids.
So it's,
it's just a fun way.
Um,
I I find to,
to begin to teach coding and computational thinking.
I was gonna I was wondering if you guys want it.
I was hoping you want it to play.
Yeah.
Um,
okay,
cool.
So let's see here.
Oh,
I have to take photographs to see this,
but that's how the kids here machine was played at Google.
Okay.
So don't,
they're going to love it.
Is it okay if I take photos of cool.
Cool.
Awesome.
So you're the one who volunteered to do the Guinea pig.
Yes.
On let's do it.
No,
this first experience is really fun.
If you want to just do what you think you should do,
it's pretty intuitive.
That sounds great.
All right,
so let's try to,
to get that button up and running.
I have to hit it with a little bit more force.
No.
See if we can get two of them going at the same time.
So the,
the other thing that happens,
uh,
whenever all these obstacles started getting placed around,
it was the,
it became a team affair.
So it might be challenging for you to see you this right now,
but I tempted or,
yeah.
Okay.
Awesome.
You made it through.
You have to go through,
through the pit of despair or the there.
There may or may not be a secret court order.
I can't,
I can't give that away.
Yeah.
What do all the other things on there do those are,
those are all um,
part of the APP.
This is so no,
no effective.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's not,
let's just say stay focused on trying to hit these buttons.
That's the way you get points.
All right.
So
it's good though.
That all is like attached to the ball.
Yes.
And so one of the,
one of the things that we do in teaching science with this is there's a lot of
things that didn't make it onto this board.
These represent the best components.
We probably made about 50 buttons.
Um,
and we would sort of like test them to see how many times hitting it does it get
triggered?
And we would teach the buttons in a really simple way.
A button is just that right there.
Um,
but that's a bad button.
So that's the hit.
Unless you wanna do you wanna try it?
Try it.
Try from up here,
sort of like this,
this upper spine point and see if you can navigate the,
the upper zone.
Winter break.
Okay.
What's the age?
So for this one,
we had anywhere from six years old to 16.
Uh,
the program was designed for fourth graders through ninth graders.
And what's the gender breakdown at Ellis best?
It was 50,
50.
About,
um,
let's see.
Let me go here.
We had a group at challengers where it was,
this is a hard one.
See 5% groups and they followed the entire process.
They were able to drop in and out that this group of girls,
you'll see them there.
They were there the entire time.
They would stay hours.
It's amazing.
That's amazing correction.
Yeah.
So now it,
now it'd be the time there'd be like,
this is too easy.
Yeah.
So this is,
this is all dynamic.
Is that right?
So like this stuff is not,
oh yeah.
Nothing here is this is all men.
This is like a block set essentially.
Like this is meant to be moved around.
Um,
yeah,
20 pops today.
You know,
if that's something that you guys built for them and then just kind of show them
how you can make contact.
Yeah.
Is it possible to program the bolt to do the course themselves?
Yes,
and we didn't have enough time to do that with them.
The pop up.
But that is the idea.
Once we've been ignited that curiosity and that passion and that interest,
then we go back and start teaching them how to program.
It's like,
oh,
you want to make that thing go?
That's code this press back.
Yeah.
There you go.
One of the biggest challenges was figuring this the surface texture out,
um,
in trying to get the ball programs,
how it responded to different textures.
Um,
it was really one of the central challenges that kids have.
My variable as well.
Did it like the sermon flexible?
Yeah.
The surfaces we worked on were not always like perfectly flat.
So there were a lot of things that made programming it to navigate the course by
itself.
Challenging.
And then you'll see Hannah's as idea.
Uh,
she,
she came up with this not make a bowl.
You can,
not that no one can make this.
Yeah.
Get the points.
SORTA exactly.
Came into the dark side over here if it worth 10,000 points,
but sort of like this vague like,
oh,
if I hit this,
like how do I hit that?
You know?
Um,
yeah,
so
part of it though,
oftentimes it's like getting kids to the point where they make something beyond
what they thought was possible initially.
Um,
which happens a lot whenever you make something that's programmable out of
trash.
Most people don't associate those two things together.
Yeah.
There were two,
two,
two takeaways or highlights for us.
One young person said,
um,
it's like being inside of a video game.
And then the other one,
so funny,
no offense,
but it's a video games made out of trash.
So,
um,
this video game is made out of trash.
Yeah.
But no one,
none of them turned away from it.
They just,
they have,
and they all had ideas on how to make it better and more competitive and harder.
So.
Great.
Sorry.
Are you going to move?
Are you going to keep using this or if you do an a pop up,
will you do it?
It'll be,
it'll be so take,
we also go through our own r and D and prototyping process and testing.
We their co designing with us how this should be presented in,
in the next phase.
I think we're deciding that we'll have all these different pieces,
but we'll keep the board empty for them to just unleash their imagination.
But we'll always have pieces around to support those students who might need a
little bit more,
um,
uh,
you know,
a little bit more push.
Um,
but this board will actually go back to 49th street elementary school in
Southeast La.
Uh,
the principal there and Ellie's best,
they were so inspired by this,
um,
that they started talking about,
well,
why,
why don't we have more of this?
And I talked to him about creating a maker space and they s there,
they said we have room.
So they're creating a maker space at 49th street,
elementary and this will live there.
Um,
so the students are,
uh,
Oh and hot when I didn't mention he graduated from the elementary school,
but he will be coming back,
um,
when they're running programs in the makerspace and he's going to be a
volunteer.
It's going to help work with the other kids.
So yeah,
and of course,
um,
what we're really focusing a lot on is,
uh,
mixed reality and k through 12 learning.
Um,
so this,
this,
we are smart cities.
Um,
we're in prototype mode.
It activated virtual reality,
augmented reality,
physical computing,
coding,
storytelling,
world building.
And this is a young,
a child experiencing virtual reality for the first time ever.
And the genesis innovation.
We have a lab,
a physical lab,
uh,
and Pico,
the Pico Robertson area.
And this was her first time I'm experiencing this.
And what she's seeing inside here is the smart city that was created by the
young people.
Um,
they're helping us codesign that next pop up experience.
whatever he gets.
We use as our asthma.
We used our asthma.
We're going to activate the Samsung three 60 camera.
Right.
So we're going to activate the Samsung three 60 camera.
Um,
what else did we use?
We use ozobots.
[inaudible].
Yes.
This was,
this was,
uh,
this was just like a virtual reality camera that was popped down in the middle
of the city.
Um,
and then this,
this girl,
she was falling around these little robots that they'd program.
So she was sort of like spinning around in a circle watching the,
the city.
The city turned around to,
um,
sort of like from the perspective of like a very small person in the middle of
the city.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so then because we,
well we ask you to join us.
Um,
we are in the process of activating programming in 25 boys and Girls Club clubs.
And,
uh,
we are in,
we're also in talks of opening,
uh,
an innovation lab in one of the boys and girls clubs in south La.
So however you can come and support or send friends,
we say,
join us.
It's a lot of fun.
[inaudible].